the United States will continue to make every
effort toward reasonable negotiation and there
can be no doubt as to our intention we do not
seek the destruction of any government now do
we covered a foot of any territory but we
insist in we will always insist that the
people of South Vietnam shall have the right
of choice the right to shape their own destiny
in free elections in the South throughout all
Vietnam under international supervision and
they shall not have any government imposed
upon them by force and terror so long as we
can prevent it we do not want an expanding
struggle with consequences that no one can
perceive now will we blister our bully our
fault our power but we will not surrender and
we will not retreat the answer to American
offers to move from the battlefield to the
conference table continues to come in the form
of high explosives aimed at American air bases
and other troop installations in the South
including the barracks of American servicemen
but in this war against people the high
explosives are not only aimed at men who
bear arms the American Embassy in Saigon
itself becomes a grim battleground seen
as Vietcong terrorists single it out for a bomb
attack it is all part of the carefully planned
and continuing campaign of terror against both
American and South Vietnamese civilians [Music]
increasingly now Americans are functioning
directly in the fight for freedom in
this far foreign corner of the earth
the risks are real just as the stakes
for which they are taken are real
but Americans risk and sometimes give all that
they have half a world away from home because
they know that once again half a world away has
become our front door if freedom is to survive in
any American hometown it must be preserved in
such places as South Vietnam and as President
Johnson has pointed out it is up to us most of the
non-communist nations of Asia cannot by themselves
and alone resist the growing light and the
grasping ambition of Asian countries because this
is truth and because we are a nation which honors
its commitments and a people committed to our
honor we intend to convince the Communists that we
cannot be defeated by force of arms or by superior
power I have asked the commanding general general
westmoreland what more he needs to meet this
mounting aggression he has told me and we will
meet his needs for the first time combat units of
the United States Marine Corps arrived in Vietnam
joining other Marines already there it is the
first time that Marines in full combat gear have
hit the beach in an active combat zone since Korea
[Music]